bonsoir bienvenue très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans savourgarde ce soir une
très grande photographe pour parler
photopolitique bonsoir Bettina reins
bonsoir et merci d'être notre grand
témoin ce soir vous venez de remettre le
prix de la photo politique à l'Assemblée
nationale c'était un nouveau prix créé
cette année par yel brun Pivet et LCP
vous allez nous révéler le nom des
gagnants tout à l'heure on reviendra
aussi sur votre carrière votre travail
sur le corps des femmes sur le genre
aussi et puis on reverra cette célèbre
photo de Jacques Chirac dans les jardins
de l'Élysée portrait officiel que vous
avez signé en 95 on l' tous déjà bien en
mémoire notre grand débat ce soir
faut-il réécrire complètement le projet
de loi sur l'immigration après son net
durcissement voté au Sénat l'aile gauche
de la majorité prévoit de détricoter ce
qu'a fait la droite sénatoriale métier
en tenstion aide médicale d'État droit
du sol alors jusqu'où la copie euh
doit-elle être remaniée y a-t-il une
majorité à l'Assemblée pour voter 1493
nous en débattons dans un instant avec
mes invité sur ce plateau enfin nos
affranchi ce soir l'économie avec Thomas
Lestavel le regard sur l'école de Yanis
roder et puis Bourbon express de
Stéphanie des pierres voilà pour le menu
on y va bettinarins ça vous regarde ça
commence
[Musique]
maintenant
c'est après les retraites la grande
bataille parlementaire de cette année
2023 le projet de loi immigration de
géralde daranin durci au Sénat arrive à
l'Assemblée fin novembre autant dire que
c'est la Manche la plus périlleuse pour
le ministre de l'Intérieur qui joue gros
tempant la majorité semble introuvable
et la macronie fracturée alors faut-il
réécrire ce texte et si oui jusqu'ù
bonsoir Bruno milen bonsoir merci d'être
là vous vous êtes député MoDem des
Yvelines vous débattez ce soir avec deux
de vos collègues Boris Vallo bonsoir
bienvenue président du groupe socialiste
à l'Assemblée nationale et députés PS
d'é Landes bonsoir Yann bouca merci
d'être là députés les républicains du
Territoire de Belfort et puis bonsoir
Pascal Briss qui n'est pas député mais
président de la Fédération des acteurs
de la solidarité je précise car vous ne
vous en cachchez pas vous êtes derrière
l'initiative de cette fameuse tribune
dans Libération transparti an avec Sacha
Houlier avec les écologistes les
socialistes pour réclamer cette
régularisation des sans papiers dans les
métiers en sension on se souvient aussi
de vous comme ancien directeur de
l'OFPRA évidemment c'est pas vos sujet
Bettina Rin on est loin de la photo mais
comme citoyenne n'hésitez pas quand vous
souhaitez interroger nos nos invités je
vous donne la parole on a besoin d'abord
de savoir à quoi ressemble ce texte
largement remanié par les sénateurs et
pour cela j'appelle mon camarade Stéphan
blackakovski le chrono de blco tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir
Miriam bonsoir à toutes et tous à
retourner pour regarder Stéphane
dakovski alors ce texte voté au Sénat
ben bonne nouvelle Miriam enfin je sais
pas si ça va réjouir Boris Valot mais en
tout cas l'adoption de la loi
immigration au Sénat ça a fait de
heureux au moins de heureux Gérald Banin
et Bruno rotillot et d'ailleurs ça peut
se comprendre parce que regardez 215
voix 210 voix pour pardon 115 contre
c'est donc le projet de lo immigration
de Gérald daranin durci par la droite de
Bruno rotillo qui a été adopté au Sénat
alors pour ce qui est du ministre de
l'Intérieur bien on peut comprendre qu'
se réjouisse vous souvenez peut-être que
en avril dernier projet de loi
immigration éta donné comme mort parce
que le président de la républiqueavait
mis de côté à cause de la réforme des
retraites et donc cette mort de son
projet de loi c'est une petite mort
aussi pour Géral daranin donc quand 6
mois plus tard son projet de loi est
adopté au Sénat et ben ça prouve qu'il
est toujours vivant on l'écoute j'ai un
instinct de survie assez développé
depuis quelques années
et donc je veux vous dire ici que la
politique la politique c'est assez
simple ça se battre pour des convictions
essayz d'avoir 100 % de ses convictions
et quand on peut en avoir 50 % et bien
on peut être plus heureux ça s'appelle
un parti de gouvernement ça s'appelle
prendre ses responsabilités mais je vous
l'ai dit il n'est pas le seul à être
heureux Géral Darmanin c'est aussi le
cas de Bruno rotailleux puisque il
estime que dès lors que la droite a
durci le texte au Sénat bien c'est une
victoire politique regardez sur le la
page d'accueil du site des républicains
il dit même le texte immigration de
Darman
n'existe plus bon vous savez ce que
c'est que l'enthousiasme des fois on
s'emballe un peu he parce que malgré
tout ce qu'il revendique comme une
victoire politique c'est d'avoir durci
les conditions de régularisation des
sans papiers dans les métiers en tension
c'est veàd que contrairement à ce qui
était prévu dans le projet de loi c'est
toujours le préfet l'administration qui
pourra décider et non pas le juge quel
son papier mérite d'être régulisé donc
en fait ça revient à une sorte de statut
qu avec la situation actuelle donc alors
que Ret lui voit une grande victoire bah
ériic siti lui il est un peu déçu il est
déçu parce qu'il aurait voulu qu'on
supprime carrément les les
régularisations de son les métiers
enention l'écoute ça me gêne ça vous
gêne ça me gêne moi j'ai toujours dit
que le principe de
régularisation était un principe
dangereux parce que ça lançait un appel
d' on a donc déjà deux courants chez
lesr le courant qui crit victoire avec
ro celui qui est déçu avec siuti il y a
aussi un troisème courant la jeune garde
regardez orien Prad lui estime que c'est
une reculade d'avoir voté ce texte au
Sénat parce que ça ne correspond pas aux
engagements pris par le parti donc voilà
c'est la zisan chez ler mais
heureusement rassurez-vous le robanquier
est passé hier à l'Assemblée voir le
groupe des députés LR il leur a dit
qu'il fallait faire équipe et ben bon
courage voilà évidemment bon courage
c'est pas si évident que ça côté
gouvernement forcément c'estes divisions
à droite B c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise nouvelle sachant qu'en
pluschine a déposé 150 amendements donc
pas de risque d'obstruction à Paris a
priori pour examiner le texte donc ce
qui reste à faire maintenant pour la
majorité c'est de modifier le texte qui
a été adopté au Sénat parce que au Sénat
les sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle ont voté pour le texte LR
qui prévoi de supprimer l'aide médicale
d'État au clandestins sauf qu'évidemment
quand le texte va arriver et bien à
l'Assemblée il n'est plus question de
voter cette suppression on écoute patria
j'ai oublé son prénom merci François
patria le patron des sénateurs
Renaissance la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale ne laissera jamais passer un
texte sans il y aura un texte final dans
lequel il y aura laame le ministre il
tient le la première ministre y tient et
l'ensemble de la majorité y tient bon
ben voilà la loi immigration arrive à
l'Assemblée 7 décembre en commission 11
décembre en séance publique donc si vous
n'avez pas le temps de dire tout ce que
vous avez dire ce soirarler donc c'est
pas gra c'est clair merci beaucoup merci
Stéphane je vais vous demander votre
position sur la version du Sénat alors
je rappelle un tout petit peu ce qu'il y
a dans le texte en quoi il a été durci
Stéphane en parlait titre délivré au cas
par cas à la discrétion du préfet pour
les travailleurs étrangers dans les
métiers en tension suppression de la me
durcissement des conditions du
regroupement familial réforme du droit
du sol avec la fin de l'accès
automatique à la nationalité à 18 ans
accès aux allocation familiale au bout
de 5 ans au lieu de 6 mois et Cotat
d'immigré avec des plafonds fixés chaque
année au Parlement Bruno liliel en
l'état est-ce que vous votez stect non
c'est clair comme réponsetiqueè cl elle
est inacceptable cette version de non
parce que on va pas raconter d'histoire
aux Français le le but de ce texte quand
il est sorti quand général Darmanin l'a
présenté cé un texte d'équilibre qui qui
essayé de pousser les curseur aussi bien
à droite qu'à gauche sur tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire de manière crédible
c'est-à-dire efficace qu'on puisse faire
là il y a des mesures le scénat mis en
place qui sont d'une efficacité totale
et qui n'apporteront rien de plus qui
sont que des postures politiciennes on
parlera vous expz alors que euh vos
alliés Renaissance on François patrina
au Sénat les quelques sénateurs modemes
les votés alors mais parce que le Sénat
c'est le Sénat nous c'est l'Assemblée
nationale c'est différent il vous choque
ce vote de vos camarades bah sur la me
par exemple oui on est on est
considérablement choqué je je vous le
confirme même s'il y a des peut-être des
améliorations à faire sur la me on ne
supprime pas la me c'est c'est c'est un
non sens à la fois budgétaire et
sanitaire donc je vois pas l'intérêt on
va revenir dans le détail pour les
républiquain à l'Assemblée alors c'est
un peu difficile à suivre euh vous vous
le votez le texte en l'état remagé par
le Sénat ou pas le Sénat a
considérablement amélioré ce texte et je
crois que ce que vient de dire Bono men
éclaire exactement le problème de la
majorité c'est qu'il veulent un texte
qui va un peu à gauche un peu à droite
je crois que si on estime qu'il y a
urgence sur la question d'immigration il
faut un texte qui soit beaucoup plus
ferme et c'est ce qu'on fait nos
collègues sénateurs je pense comme RTI
qu' on aurait pu aller un peu plus loin
mais je pense surtout comme Laurent
voquier qu'il faut qu'on fasse équipe et
qu'on parle d'une seule voix à partir de
la commission des lois à partir de
l'hémicycle pour obtenir le plus
possible sur ce texte immigration donc
en l'état oui je le voterai d'accord
très bien Boris valallot qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de la la version du Sénat
c'est une horreur absolue c'est à la
fois une faute morale et une rupture
politique y compris avec l'histoire
politique des républicain on est très
loin de de de Jacques Chirac euh c'est
une droite qui fait jonction avec
l'extrême droite reprenant s'agissant
des allocation familial les propositions
de Marine Le Pen dans son dans son
programme franchement c'est une honte et
tout ça avec la la la complicité du
ministre de l'Intérieur qui est heureux
de d'avoir fait voter son texte et avec
les votes
des membres sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle parce que François patria
a beau dire ce qu'il vient de ce queon
vient d'entendre il a quand même voté la
suppression de l'Ame donc tout ça est
parfaitement honteux en réalité c'est
une loi essentiellement destinée à
pourrir la vie des étrangers et j' en
situation irrégulière mais franchement
pas que vous l'avez constaté puisque il
faudra 5 ans par exemple pour pouvoir
avoir des allocations familiales c'est 6
mois aujourd'hui alors que c'est des
familles qui qui qui travaillent qui
payent des impôts qui payent des
cotisations sociales qui participent à
l'économie du pays qui participent à la
solidarité nationale et ben franchement
je vous dis je suis eux qui équeuré
parce que tout ça participe d'un climat
euh qui est un N Pasin et qui est un
grand mensonge au français si si on
pense vraiment qu'on va régler quoi que
ce soit avec ces propositions là c'est
un grand mensonge alors il y a une
lecture à l'Assemblée c'est bien pour ça
qu'on va on va en parler vous n'êtes pas
député je vais pas vous demander si vous
votez ou pas mais qu'est-ce qu'elle vous
inspire cette version d'urci au Sénat
d'un mot beaucoup
d'inquiétude
c'est pas un durcissement comme je
l'entends ici comme ailleurs c'est une
bascule un saut dans le vide est ce
qu'il faut prendre en compte c'est non
seulement le le texte l'accumulation le
déchaînement de mesures que vous
rappeliez qui sont toute issue de tiroir
ça fait des années et des années que
certaines et certains pens la nouveauté
c'est qu'il y a une majorité pour cela
on n'est pas dans un aen texte comme on
en a vu depuis des années qui complique
la vie des gens qui à mon avis à chaque
fois sucde de l'IND du désordre non on
est dans autre chose on est dans la
tonalité des débats au Sénat au Sénat la
chambre de la
sagesse on est dans les mesures prises
ça témoigne de quoi dans un déchaînement
qui livre à l'in vindicte désormais
l'immigration par principe les immigrés
par nature et qui notamment tourne le
dos à un principe républicain
fondamental affaibli en panne vous savez
je suis pas un angélique hein directeur
de l'OF pr j'en ai fait tomber des
statutes de Chechen pour menace
terroriste l'intégration est en panne
dans ce pays mais ce vote là ce qui a
été dit là ce qui est voté là c'est
tourner le dos au principe même de
l'intégration républicaine et donc oui
je vous le dis avec parce que je crois
qu'il faut prendre la mesure de ce qui
se passe je je vous le dis avec beaucoup
devité de sincérité et de gravité je dis
aux uns et aux autres et notamment
certains que je connais je peux pas
croire qu'il soit dans cette dérive là
drivve basculent on entend vos mots
Pascal brille et votre inquiétude alors
on va entrer dans le détail à présent
c'est le totem de ce texte la
régularisation des S papiers qui
travaillent dans les métiers en tension
et pour prendre la mesure des besoins
sur le terrain direction Deol près de
châteurou dans l'Indre Clément perouau
et Ivan anavion se sont rendus dans le
plus grand restaurant routier de France
qui peinene à recruter à la fois en
salle et en cuisine
reportage
l'escale est une institution le plus
grand resto routier de France installé
près de châurou sert tous les jours de
400 à 600
couverts tous les jours mais plus toute
l'année désormais l'établissement
connaît des périodes de fermeture je
suis obligé de fermer l'établissement
une semaine la semaine prochaine par
manque d'effectif manque de personnel
particulièrement en salle plus personne
ne veut servir plus personne ne veut
travailler surtout le soir le weekend
c'est c'est catastrophique voilà
monsieur bonjour de couvert si vous
voulez bieness par ici longtemps ouvert
2424 l'escale ferme désormais à minuit
pour les mêmes raisons et alors qu'il a
la clientelle pour les remplir le patron
est contraint de laisser certaines
salles vides tu es triste et si j'étais
seul à constaté ce truc là mais un
collègue là de à côté là il ferme tous
les dimanche depuis le 15 octobre à
cause de manque de personnel moi ça fait
45 ans je fais ça je suis pas mort
l'escale propose à ses serveurs un
salaire de 14,50 € minimum de l'heure
c'est 2,20 de plus que la moyenne de la
profession mais cela ne suffit pas à
susciter des vocations tartine du
chauffeur en cuisine aussi la pénurie de
main d'œuvre se fait sentir alors
régulariser des travailleurs étrangers
pourrait-il être une piste pour le
secteur de la restauration Domini Thomas
est mitigé sur cette question
régulariser des gars qui font depuis 5
ans qui dans la peur oui ça pas mal pas
mal non ça sera un petit pourcentage
d'amélioration on est tellement loin et
c'est 200000 po dans la restauration
sont à
pourir restation
200000 actuellement l'escale cherche à
recruter 5 serveurs en salle et tr
cuisiniers
Yan Bouard qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
à ce restaurateur il y a des besoins et
il a beau augmenter les salaires il y a
pas de personnel cette pénurie de
manœuvre elle est là elle existe et les
employeurs la réclamament le MDEF la
réclam Thierry Marx pour lumi la réclame
il y a quand même un problème vous le
reconnaissez et vous avez raison mir
Kawa il y a un problème il y a 200000
emplois qui sont pourvoir dans la
restauration en France et y a 2 milliion
a 3 millions de chômeurs donc oui il y a
un problème plus globalement sur notre
approche du travail mais cette façon de
dire on a 200000 emplois non pour pourvu
donc on devrait régulariser 200000
personnes ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
redéfinisse plus globalement oui mais
qu'on commence par 10000 puis allons
jusqu'à 200000 s'il manque 200000
personnes allons jusqu'au bout soyons
cohérents pour ceux qui revendiquent qui
revendiquent cette mesure mais ce me
suur vous dit aussi que la
régularisation généralisée comme a été
proposé dans l'article 3 elle va régler
d'un trait de CR d'un trait de crayon
pardon finalement les problèmes qu'il y
a ne serait-ce que dans la restauration
mais c'est 200000 dans restauration
c'est combien dans le bâtiment c'est
combien cette intégration par le travail
qu'est-ce qui vous fait peur c'est
l'appel d'air que vous Déon éidemment et
la réalité je finis juste sur cette
question là c'est que dans notre pays le
travail ne rémunère plus et ça c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on se MRE
d'accord quelqu'un qui vient travailler
de nuit qui travaille le weekend et qui
est payé 14,50 € de l'heure avec les
charges qui sont prélevées avec les
impôts qu' doit payer avec le coût du
carburant mais évidemment que ce n'est
pas compétitif et que parfois on voit
malheureusement nous qui sommes députés
dans nos circonscriptions des gens qui
nous disent qu'ils auraient intérêt à
rester à la maison plutôt que de
travailler c'est ce rapport là au
travail qu'on doit redéfinir plutôt que
de se dire qu'on doit régulariser celles
et ceux qui sont en situation
irrégulière et qui donc ont enfreint par
le le par leur rentrée sur le territoire
la loi française alors pour bien
comprendre aujourd'hui c'est l'article 4
bis voté par la droite ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on change rien c'est ça
cet article 4 bis c'est les préfets au
cas par cas selon leur propre pouvoir
discrétionnaire qui décide de
régulariser ou pas comment comment
s'appliquerait cet article au Sénat et
et en quoi il faudrait le changer qui
veut répondre juste peut-être pour
revenir sur sur le cas d'espèce là euh
aujourd'hui on estime qu' à peu près 20
% de ceux qui travaillent dans la
restauration qui sont des travailleurs
étrangers en situation irrégulière ça
veut pas dire qu'il payent pas leur
cotisation hein c'est là la grosse
hypocrisie c'est qui participe déjà de
la solidarité nationale et du
financement de la protection de la
protection sociale pas forcément du
travail noir c'est que c'est vrai oui et
c'est vrai d'autres secteurs d'activité
parce qu'on pourrait évoquer le bâtiment
les travaux publics la propreté les
services d'aide à domicile il y a
beaucoup de ces gens-là qui vivent des
vies impossibles parce qu'on maintient
cette hypocrisie moi je crois à la
valeur du travail
voyez les défenseurs les plus
prétendument acharnés du travail en
réalité sont ceux qui vont empêcher ces
travailleurs étrangers d'avoir des
papiers et de cotiser normalement et de
d'avoir une vie une vie ordinaire je
crois aussi que c'est un levier
d'intégration absolument considérable
voilà parce que dans l'histoire on sait
que le le le l'intégration elle s'est
faite par par le travail c'est une
hypocrisie c'est pas des des
travailleurs étrangers qui prendraient
le travail des Français ça a été dit
d'une certaine manière j'ai pas dit ça
du tout toutur bah comme il a beaucoup
de gens avec droite je me pose
question en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que aujourd'hui c'est des
postes qui sont pas pourvus par nos nos
no nos compatriotes français il y a un
un un potentiel absolument considérable
il y a une
hypocrisie consacré il y a un levier
d'intégration considérable ça sera pas
suffisant mais c'est important moi je
crois qu'il faut aller àtre personnel
c'est position des socialistes bien
au-delà des métiers en attention on
évoque par exemple alors attendez parce
que vous savezs bien êtes pas
majoritaire làdessus donc qui peut
peut-être atrir comme compromis oui mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que l'hôterie
restauration n'est pas un secteur en
tension aujourd'hui il est pas sur la
liste des secteurs en tension mesurez le
bien aussi pour vous dire que en réalité
la problématique elle est beaucoup plus
large que ça et quand on travaille ben
je crois quand on paye ses cotisations
sociales c'est bon pour tous les
travailleurs la régularisation ça évite
le dumping social vous disiez que le
travail ne payez pas bah quand on vous
propose de Smic à 1500 ou 1600 € vous
êtes pas au rendez-vous quand il s'agit
de mieux payer les travailleurs alors
j'aimerais comprendre la situation
actuelle parce que on parle du rôle du
préfet c'est bien lui qui décide de
délivrer le titre de séjour donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui changerait demain avec le
Sénat et qu'est-ce qui changerait si
c'était la loi initiale qui était votée
est-ce qu'on nous parle d'un pouvoir
discrétionnaire et d'un droit opposable
honnêtement ce qui a été voté au Sénat
ça change rien dans les faits donc on
avance pas et il y a quand même si on
veut être assez didactique il y a trois
sortes de
travailleurs immigré en France il y a
ceux qui
ont des des papiers des cartes de séjour
qui sont renouvelable et tous dans nos
circonscriptions alorsx ils sont là
légalement sur le territoire ils ont une
carte de séjour renouvelable et tous
dans dans nos circonscrition que soit Y
en boucar soit Boris valallot tous les
ans on intervient auprès des préfectures
pour les renouvellements de ces de
séjour des gens qui sont là depuis 10 15
ans qui sont obligés de renouveler leur
cadre de séjour à chaque fois ça c'est
une hypocrisie totale on peut pas
laisser ces gens-là avec une épée de
Damocles audessus de la tête se dire que
jamais ils n'auront de papier définitifs
alors qu'ils sont intégrés alors ça
c'est pas l'article 3 c'est pas
l'article 3 pour que ce soit clair dans
la tte non mais ce sont aussi des
étrangers mais pour que ce soit clair
dans la tête des gens faisons
lerégulière la deuxième catégorie c'est
ceux qui n'ont pas de papier mais qui
ont un contrat de travail déjà moi faut
qu'on m'explique comment on arrive à
faire ça mais ils ont un contrat de
travail ils payent des cotisations Boris
Valo l'a répété ils payent des
cotisations retraite dont ils ne verront
jamais la couleur et ces gens-là pareil
ils cotisent ils participe à à la vie de
la nation et pareil épé de damoclesè ils
ne savent pas de quoi demain sera fait
c'est pas un traitement humain enfin
honnêtement j'ai beau ne pas être
socialiste Boris Vallot le sait très
bien je suis au modème c'est pas un
traitement humain après qu'on regarde la
situation attz après qu'on regarde la
situation de ces gens-là dans le détail
pour ne pas accorder la régularisation à
tout le monde parce qu'il faut quand
même qu'on fasse attention ça c'est
autre chose mais on peut pas juste
balayer en disant non ces gens-l on les
régularise pas et le trème les troèm
catégories de de de travailleurs
immigrés ce sont ceux qui
malheureusement pour eux malheureusement
pour eux participe parce qu'on ne
dénonce pas assez en France cette espèce
de marchandisation d'esclavagisme
moderne qui fait qu'on va employer des
gens au noir d'accord et ça c'est juste
scandaleux ces gens n'ont aucun droit
donc que ces gens-là puissent aller en
préfecture en disant mais monsieur voilà
j'ai travaillé pendant tant de temps les
deux dernières années avec ou pas enfin
en général des fausses des fausses
feuilles fiches de paye moi je suis
d'accord parce que ça permettra aussi de
dénoncer ceux qui participent à cette
traite ce que j'appelle l'esclavagisme
moderne dans le monde du travail et ça
c'est aussi intolérable voilà trois
catégories de travailleurs immigrés
trois façons de réag je comprends que
vous voulez revenir c'est votre droit le
plus absolu de parlementaire c'est le
sens même du débat à l'article initial
concernant les métiers en tenstion
Pascal Briss il serait bon que que ce
débat se fasse dans la clarté sur cette
question là parce que les habillages
politiciens c'est en permanence
insupportable mais sur des questions
aussi fondamentales dans l'état du pays
çait plus que jamais la réalité c'est
que ce que le Sénat a voté c'est un
recul par rapport à une situation de
régularisation possible qui est déjà
très limité est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
ça précisément tout simplement parce que
sén la majorité du Sénat a récusé la
proposition du gouvernement qui était
intéressante sur le principe qui disait
possibilité de régularisation à mon sens
insuffisante parce que c'était un titre
de séjour d'un an vous avez pas un
patron qui va embaucher pour un an et
cetera mais enfit il y avait quelque
chose d'intéressant le Sénat dit non ça
non et en plus mais des conditions sur
l'utilisation par les les préfets d'une
circulaire aujourd'hui la circulaire
Vals qui leur permet dans certains cas
de régulariser des travailleurs et dont
ils font un usage extrêmement
parsimonieux donc vous voyez bien qu'en
réalité là on a quelque chose votre
reportage le montrer on est un peu chez
les fous quand même là dans ce débat
mais vraiment enfin je veux dire moi je
peux pas aller chez un boulanger on est
tous dans la même situation est-ce qu'on
peut pas dire ce dire simplement que il
y a des besoins dans ce dans C dans ce
dans les entreprises de ce pays je veux
dire c'est qu même la force de
l'économie de la République c'est à la
droite hein qui il faut s'adresser parce
que raison le député a raison de dire
queil y a des inquiétudes chez les
salariés sur le niveau des salaires sur
la concurrence éventuelle ça existe ça
il faut regarder moi je suis pas aveugle
sur ce qui travaille le pays sur les
inquiétudes sur l'immigration donc on
doit être dans une situation on doit
pouvoir régulariser pour des hommes et
des femmes qui peuvent travailler qui ne
demande que ça le paradoxe est quand
même incroyable vous avez au Sénat des
gens qui vous font un truc qui vous
explique que il faut arrêter les aides
au logement al ça j'aimerais bien savoir
comment les gens vont trouver un
logement dans ces conditionsl il faut
les aides ils font ils sont là que pour
les aides et en même temps on veut pas
qu'ils bosse quand même trouver quelque
chose de simple qui est de dire il y a
des besoins dans les entreprises il y a
des gens qui ne demandent qu'à
travailler qui dans ce cas-là ne
coûteront plus un souit ce soit
disparaîtront des redards de qui que ce
soit vivront tranquillement plutôt que
d'idéologiser et de livrer les gens à la
vindicte c'est c'est bien compris
le point il est technique mais il tourne
autour de l'encadrement des préfets si
je comprends bien l'article 3 c'était un
droit opposable direct pour les les
personnes qui travaillent étrangères en
situation irrégulière et là on revient
au pouvoir discrétionnaire de préfet
Florent Bour bouier qui est le
rapporteur spécial de ce projet de loi
il était notre invité hier il propose
une sorte d'intermédiaire entre le Sénat
et la version initial écoutez vous nous
direz si vous êtes prêts à voter nous
nous sommes partis dans le texte initial
avec un droit opposable automatique où
personne au fond ne pouvait dire
grandchose c'était vous répondez à tel
critère vous aurez le titre de séjour
bon le sénad dit c'est le pouvoir
discrétionnaire au contraire général et
absolu du préfet moi je pense qu'on peut
avoir un dispositif où le
préfet va pouvoir s'opposer mais sur des
motifs et qui sont présentés dans la loi
voilà une forme d'équilibre parce que
c'est c'est aussi ça quand on n pas de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
prené par le rapporteur spécial le
rapporteur Renaissance sur le projet de
loi parce qu'elle brise disait qu'il
fallait qu'il y ait de la clarteté je
veux dire soit on revient au texte
initial ce qui paraissait être dit donc
je vous dis que pour ce qui me concerne
il est très insuffisant donc c'est non
déjà soit on est encore dans une sorte
de compromis de en même temps je y a un
certain nombre de principes qui sont pas
divisibles soit c'est un droit soit ça
n'en est pas un et et pour le contester
il y a les tribunaux pour ça et
j'entendais la première ministre qui
pour rassurer je sais pas bien qui
disait non mais ce sera quelques
milliers de cas par an il y a 7000
régularisation par le travail chaque
année si c'est pour nous expliquer qu'en
réalité ça ne va rien changer sortons de
cette de cette hypocrisie je pour pour
montrer l'absurdité dans laquelle on est
et je crois que Pascal BR a donné des
bons exemples vous avez parfois des des
mineurs non accompagnés qui arrivent à
15 ans après un parcours migratoire don
leur peau supporte les cicatrices je
l'ai vu de mes yeux ça été très dur qui
ont traversé la Méditerranée qui sont s
sortis il y en a beaucoup d'autres qui
s'y sont noyés et qui vont au lycée qui
vont au C de formation des apprentis qui
participent au concours de Meilleur
apprentis de France qui ont un maître de
stage qui veut les embaucher et là on
peut pas les embucher on ne pourrait pas
les embaucher alors Yan Bouard c'est
important d'avoir voilà la réaction de
la droite à ce qui est proposeé
ce qui est dessiné à ce stade de la
négociation parce qu' il y en a beaucoup
en coulisse je crois que Gérald haranin
va recevoir tous les député de la
majorité est-ce que ce qu'a dit le
rapporteur vous êtes prêt à le voter
réaction à ce qu'a dit le rapporteur à
ce que vient de dire Boris Ballo d'abord
sur ce qu' dit le rapporteur il montre
exactement pourquoi on s'est opposé à
l'article 3 parce qu'il fait appel d'air
il le dit lui-même c'est un droit
opposable c'est qu'à partir du moment on
remplira trois critères on va pouvoir re
devant le tribunal ça sera automatique
il le dit c'est une régularisation
automatique c'est exactement pourquoi on
s'est opposé à C article 3 et sur
l'article sur quoi il s'av
léèrement encadr les préfets tout en le
laissant du pouvoir ce serait possible
ça de trouver un vote ou pas pour les
répon appelle la circulaire Val
ditaujourd'hui circulaire Val cétait un
gouvernement que j'imagine pas député
que vous auriez soutenu qui a fait cette
circulaire j'
l'ession on a des préfets tétanisés
aujourd'hui vous savez quand vous êtes
un étrangerê vous ne pouvez pas obtenir
un rendez-vous dans une préfecture c'est
nous qui les recevons enfin vous le
savez bien collègue c'est nous qui les
recevons c'est plus facile de rencontrer
son député ème vous a raison sur la
questionenti qui est arrivé
miteenis lui puiss régularisé mais la
question qu'on traite pas qu'on aborde
jamais depuis le début c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de tous ceux qui dev être
éloigné expuls qu'onarrive pas éloign
expuls qui n pas le droit d'être là
parce que la réité et la question que se
POS les Français c'est ça aussi parce
que les Français tous mais vous répz
pasment pas ce qui n'ont rien à faire là
répz tout un volet sur les expulsions
qui sont simplifié je propose que on
vous réinvite pour ce débat parce que on
voulait aussi parler du deuxè totème
l'aide médicale d'État Bruno men il faut
absolument la rétablir c'est une enfin
c'est une aberration cette suppression
d'abord c'est uneocusie totale parce
qu'on supprime la me mais on maintient
la MU c'est l'aide médicale d'urgence
enfinur limité aux maladies graves et
douleurs aigu vous imaginez si on avait
pas eu SAG du gouvernement vous vous
imaginez si vous avez pas eu si vous
aviez pas eu la me pendant la crise du
covid non mais les gens se rendent
compte ou pas il faut dire la vérité aux
gens tous ces les immigrés dont parlait
Boris qui ont eu des tragets pour
arriver jusqu'en France qui sont
épouvantables certains viennent avec des
maladies infectieuses et il faut les
soigner tout de suite pour éviter les
risques de pour eux déjà pour éviter les
risques pandémie monsieur Boucard je ne
vous ai pas interrompu donc laissez-moi
terminer laame son avantage c'est qu'on
sait la chiffrer 1,2 milliards 1,2
milliards ok vous supprimez la me vous
croyez pour autant que les médecins ils
l'ont dit sur tous les TS le ministre de
la Santé l'a dit aussi hipocrate vous
croyez que les médecins vont arrêter de
soigner les gens mais non mais alors
tout ça va disparaître non pas dans les
limbes mais dans les budgets des
hôpitaux qui sont déjà exangles et au
final de toute façon c'est le c'est le
citoyen qui Pera donc arrêtons arrêtons
de faire croire aux gens qu'en
supprimant la me on va arrêter l'appel
d' vous ne réécrirez pas clment
d'Hippocrate pour avoir les voix de LR
j'ai bien compris qu'on regarde
attentivement ceux qui viennent faire
entre guillemets du tourisme médical
pour se soigner en France s'il y a
vraiment une raison valable ou pas ça
c'est une chose donc ça c'est le panier
de soins que vous voulez bien réduireer
sur le panier de soin il à transiger
voilà non mais il y a peut-être des
incohérences monsieur Vallot moi je
comprends pas pourquoi on donne le
panier de soins qu'au bout de 3 mois par
exemple et pourquoi le panier de soins
complet est à 9 mois allez qui VE voilà
à mon sens Pier soin il doit être donné
jusqu'à ce qu'on obtienne ou pas euh son
autorisation de rester sur le territoire
voilà d'Hippocrate les médecins vous
l'avez compris s tiendront il y a 3500
médecins qui ont signé une tribune pour
dire que il désobéirit et qu'il
continueraiit à soigner moi je vois
aussi une sorte de serment d'hypocrite
je rappelle la majorité gouvernementale
a soutenu au Sénat cette suppression
mais je suis pas sénateur a pas le
gouvernement que vous soutenez a émis un
avis de sagesse c'est remettant d'
na bien la procédure Paraire S se on se
mouille pas on on se mouille pas même
enfin on sait très bien quels sont les
équilibres politiques dans une assemblée
ça veut dire qu'on s'en remet à la
majorité sénatoriale c'est-à-dire à la
suppression mon excusez-moi pas sur tous
les textes il y a des textes qui sont
quand même beaucoup plus emblématiques
brun sur la me me dis pas le contraire
bah sur la me nous on est pour toujours
on se en coulise en tout casisabeth
borne a dit qu'elle reviendrait sur
cette suppression et a recadré Géral
vous êtes prêt à accepter si vous
obtenez autre chose les voies de LR sont
essentielles déterminantes pour obtenir
un vote à à laisser revenir l'aide
médicale d'État ou si on ne revient pas
sur sa suppression vous ne votez pas le
T faut même expliqu be télpectateur que
supprimer la me ça veut pas dire qu'il y
a plus rien on parit une maladie
infectieuse évidemment ça fait partie de
ce qui continuera à être soigné par la
mu les la vaccination c'est ce qui
continuera à être soigné par la mu parce
que personne dans ce pays veut qu'on
laisse mourir des gens qui c'est
impossible de savoir ce qui est aigu ou
grave les médecins font de la médecine
et moi je ne vous sa P la crise
sanitaire je ne veux jamais contredire
un médecin qui expliquait qu'il fallait
faire telle ou telle chose nous nous
sommes là pour faire la loi donc nous
allons essayer à partir du 4 décembre
prochain de faire de faire la loi très
correctement moi je pense qu'il y a
quand même une dérive je dis pas que
tout est excessif dans les me je ne dis
pas qu'il faut la supprimer complètement
mais je pense qu'il y a une dérive on
est passé de 140000 bénéficiaires en
2008 à plus de 400000 aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y a quand même un sujet sur cette
questionlà et le vote du Sénat va
permettre d'aborder correctement
correctement ce sujetl par les gens se
vont de toute façon soign on voit que il
y a je ne sais pas comment appeler ça
c'est pas une voie de passage c'est un
trou de souris pour obtenir un vote sur
ce texte c'est très mal en
mancher je voudrais poser une dernière
question elle les politique celle-là si
on va tout droit vers le 493 il y aura
une motion de censure ça vous essaierez
de la déposer moi en tout cas je voterai
la motion de censure effectivement je
pensejet VO les LR réussissent à être
suffisamment nombreux pour déposer cette
motion les socialistes qu'est-ce qu'ils
font saz je la vote il la vote pas pour
renverser le gouvernement
ce so ça c'est pas faux euh donc on
rigne pas mais voyez je vais pas
demander au gouvernement euh de prendre
les mesures de Monsieur retaillot de
Monsieur sooti de Monsieur Pradier qui
trouvent que c'est une reculade que ça
n'est pas ass voterez pas la censure
c'est très clair les socialistes et vous
êtes le président du groupe socialiste
ne voteront pas la censure et donc le
493 peut-être une solution pour faire
passer cette réforme mais peut-être que
je m'avance une faute
politique 4 des débats il y a des débats
qu'on ne peut pas perdre à l'Assemblée
nationale quand on est dans la majorité
il y a des débats qu'on peut perdre si
on explique la justesse des mesures
qu'on a mises si on trouve le parfait
équilibre dans ce texte moi je veux bien
être battu parce que les Français
verront les hypocrisies d'un côté comme
de l'autre merci on s'arrête là le débat
ne fait que commencer je rappelle à nos
téléspectateurs qu'à partir du 11
décembre il arrive dans l'hémicycle et
vous pourrez le suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur LCP vous reviendrez j'en
suis sûr d'ici là vous restez avec moi
Bettina reins dans une dizaine de
minutes les partis prix de nos
affranchis ce soir on va recevoir Yanis
roder qui revient sur les résultats des
évaluations nationales dévoilé par le
ministre Gabriel hatal Thomas Lestavel
nous parle des chiffres tout chaud du
chômage ils sont tombés ce matin et ils
repartent à la hausse et vous Stéphanie
Despierre dans Bourbon Express quel est
le menu la deuxème réunion des
rencontres de Saint-Denis entre Emmanuel
Macron et les partis politiques la
politique de la chaise vide on verra ça
tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure les amis
mais d'abord on va parler Bettina reins
avec vous de ce prix de la photo
politique lancée cette année à
l'Assemblée avec LCP vous en étiez la
présidente d'honneur la vice-présidente
d'honneur VI présidente du jury on va
voir les photos du palmarès on va aussi
revenir sur votre carrière regardez
c'est dans l'invitation de léosux et on
en parle longuement juste
après si on vous invite bettinarins
c'est parce que vous allez dans quelques
minutes nous révéler le palmarès 2023 du
prix de la photographie politique un
événement organisé avec avec l'Assemblée
nationale vous êtes la vice-présidente
d'honneur du jury photographe
bettinarins vous avez été mannequin
journaliste et galeriste dans une autre
vie votre carrière derrière l'objectif
vous l'avez passé à photographier les
femmes et leur
corps célèbre comme anonyme vous aimez
la
provoque susciter des réaction oui
est-ce que c'est pas ça d'être un
artiste c'est c'est se rebeller contre
les é toute fait et et et faire bouger
les lignes des striptiseuses de vos
premiers clichés aux femmes détenues en
2014 vous ne cessez de questionner la
féminité mais vous avez aussi
photographié des hommes politiques
notamment parmi eux Jacques Chirac dont
vous êtes proche vous signez même son
portrait officiel en
1995 dans les jardins de l'Élysée une
première photographier le pouvoir vous
connaissez et votre avis compte parmi
les photos en L cette année ce moment de
décontraction du ministre du Travail en
plein hémicycle mais aussi un regard
celui de ce jeune gendarme lors d'une
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites ou encore ce cliché de Marine
Le Pen de dos devant un champ en flamme
au Sénégal alors vous qui avez la
réponse une question nous brûle les
lèvres qui est le lauréa du prix de la
photographie politique cette année voilà
roulement de temp
le gagnant est donc le gagnant est
Ludovic marin pour cette photo
absolument magnifique du président de la
République devant le tableau de rambranc
à
Amsterdam on s'est tous d'abord on s'est
tous accordé finalement au bout de
plusieurs tours enfin ça c'est le jeu de
d'un jury mais on s'est tous fait avoir
par cette image VO parce qu'on a pensé
que la main qui se tendait était celle
du président Macron mais c'est une photo
absolument in sa main c'est la main du
conservateur qui est dans le même axe et
et donc il a pas le même la même manche
de costume que le costume du Président
si vous regardez bien il y a deux
silhouettesosé et les regards sont
complètement inversés puisque ce sont
les drapiers qui regardent Emmanuel
Macron je vous propose d'écouter
Ludovique marin donc le lauréade ce prix
lancé cette année grand photographe de
la FP habitué à suivre les présidents
qui commentent cette photo prise à
Amsterdam
on est en voyage officiel au Pays-Bas et
le président Macron avec sa femme
effectue une visite d'État au Pays-Bas
le Premier ministre l'invite à
participer à un dîner de travail à
l'intérieur du Rix museéum
et en fait en face de moi il y a ce
tableau de rambran du syndque de la
guilde des drapiers donc le président va
regarder le tableau de dos à nous et
tout d'un coup le conservateur lui
montre le tableau de droite et c'est à
ce moment-là que ce apparaît le visage
du président avec ce bras qui n'est pas
le sien cette photo m'a m'a m'a
intéressé parce que ces drapiers qui
regardent le visiteur d'habitude regarde
tout d'un coup quelqu'un de connu qui
qui vient s'ajouter à leur champ de
vision je ne sais pas qui étaient les
gens que les drapiers regardaient quand
le peintre rambran à peince tableau mais
là en l'occurrence c'est regardez qui
vient nous rendre visite ou regardez qui
est là ou tiens tu as vu c'est le
président de la République française et
en fait c'est ça qui m'a qui m'a amusé
le regard c'est de me dire que j'allais
faire vivre avec ma photo modestement
une espèce de deè histoire de ce regard
des drapiers de rambran voilà incroyable
photo c'est quoi une bonne photo
politique pour vous alors une bonne
photo politique c'est avant tout une
bonne photo euh c'est une bonne photo
qui doit être vue et comprise par tous
ça a été une espèce d'ambigué au début
j'étais la seule non politique dans ce
jury et il s'arrêtait parfois sur des
photos qui n'étaient pas vraiment de
bonnes photos mais qu'il qui leur
racontait des histoires parce qu'ils
étaient là parce que tel personnage
n'avait pas l'habitude d'être dans cette
position et je leur disais mais attendez
on ne cherche pas une anecdote de
l'Assemblée ou une anecdote politique on
cherche une image alors bien sûr il faut
que ce soit lié à la politique d'une
manière ou d'une autre mais c'est vrai
que c'est un décor assez austère la
politique toujours des costumes cravates
ou des tailleurs stricts des foules des
des forêts de caméra il y a des il y a
des constances dans le cadre et donc
l'instant pour décorceter ce monde c'est
l'instant c'est c'est d'ailleurs c'est
la fameuse phrase de carbisson qu'on
cite tout le temps dans tous les sens et
qu'on cite de travers mais mais c'est
mais c'est l'instant décisif je ve dire
quand il choisit de prendre sa photo il
y a une main en l'air et ça veut dire
quelque chose et alors ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'on a récompensé trois
photos justement on va voir la deuxème
deux sont de dos justement celle-là est
de dos c'est celle de Ludovique marin
une autre image qui détonne c'est celle
de justement Sébastien
Leban prix spécial du jury que vous avez
remis absolument Marine Le Pen de dos
une main dans la poche face à un ch en
feu au Sénégal qu'est-ce qu'elle raconte
cette photo B cette photo d'abord elle
est pas s'en rappeler une espèce d'image
symbolique du président Mao ou de
quelque chose comme ça dans cette
posture le monde est en feu ça brûle
devant elle elle a l'air de elle a l'air
de demander aux gens de l'accompagner de
de je sais pas est-ce que c'est pour
éteindre l'incendie est-ce que c'est
pour l'allumer plus fort l'anecdote veut
que ce soit elle qui a mis le feu au
champ parce que chaque année on enflamme
les champs pour qu'il repousseent mieux
et donc on lui a proposé dans ce voyage
j'ai oublié où c'était que que qu'elle
allume elle-même le feu donc c'est une
espèce de triple quadruple symbolique
incroyable enfin le prix des députés
puis ensuite je voudrais qu'on prenne le
temps de parler aussi de de vos
expositions de votre travail ça c'est un
autre jury il a choisi de mettre à
l'honneur une jeune femme d'une
vingtaine d'années elle s'appelle Lili
Chavance avec un visage très jeune lui
aussi un CRS au regard intense et
déterminé on le voit éclaboussé par la
peinture rouge des opposants à la
réformeure verte des opposants à la
réforme des retraites là encore c'est
c'est une histoire de regard capturé
c'est une histoire de regard elle est
absolument formidable cette photo et
quand on sait qu'elle a été faite par
une jeune femme de 22 ans et que pour
prendre cette image ça veut dire qu'on
est au premier rang des opposants des
manifestants elle est tout près quand
elle fait ça on l'a vu tout à l'heure
elle est toute menue c'est une jeune
femme fragile qui est là devant cette
foule de CRS et ben voilà c'est un
symbole magnifique et le regard de ce de
ce jeune garçon et alors vous n'êtes pas
une photographe du politique mais quand
même vous avez suivi un ancien président
dans ces derniers mois de campagne
Jacques Chirac qui va vous proposer en
1995 ce portrait vous l'avez raconté
mais moi j'aimerais quand même raconter
l'anecdote de Jacques Pilan vous
choisissez une photo vous arrivez avec
une planche contact vous le mettez dans
le jardin de l'Élysée et qu'est-ce qui
se passe alors oui alors c'est un peu
plus long que çazy donc donc j'ai passé
4 jours entre les deux tours à le
photographier je ne l'ai pas quitté
c'était le c'était le nom du jeu il ne
me faisait jamais sortir donc pendant 4
jours je l'ai suivi je les ai suivi j'ai
suivi la famille j'ai déjeuné avec eux
j'ai dîné avec eux et et ensuite ils ont
enlevé un certain nombre d'images mais
c'était leur droit ensuite je rentre
chez chez moi le dimanche soir il est
élu président de la République et là
quelqu'un me dit tu sais il va peut-être
te demander de faire sa photo officielle
et puis le mardi matin Jacques Pilan
m'appelle il me dit est-ce que vous
pouvez venir tout de suite donc je lâche
ce que je suis en train de faire je pars
à l'élisé j'arrive le même jour que les
chiracs qui découvrent les lieux et et
je fais le tour Jacques Pilon qui
connaît bien l'endroit il était avec
mitteran tout ce temps me fait me fait
une espèce de visite de tout je vois que
tout est très doré chaque lieu me
rappelle une photo officielle je veux
dire il y a la bibliothèque c'est déjà
fait et donc vous le sortez donc je dis
on va le mettre jardin on va le mettre
dans les jardins parce que j'avais cette
image de je sais pas pour moi Shirak
c'était un espèce d'homme des grandes
plaines comme ça il me faisait penser je
sais pas il avait un côté Far West et et
donc et donc Chirac trouve que c'est une
très bonne idée pilant aussi euh la
photo se fait en très peu de temps faut
bien imaginer que il est là depuis 48h
il a autre chose à faire que de poser
pour pour un photographe ou une
photographe et et donc le lendemain je
reviens avec mes planches contact et sur
les planches contact à l'époque on est
en argentique donc on vient avec des
contacts je crois qu'il y en a neuf
différents et j'ai mis des croix mon
système c'est MRE trois croix quand la
photo que j'aime et Jacques Pilan à la
petite loupe que je lui apporte et il
regarde et sur une image qui doit avec
le numéro 7 il regarde c'est mes trois
croix il me dit oui non on va prendre
celle d'à côté qui est le numéro 8 alors
je lui dis mais c'est juste pour me
contrarier quoi vous êtes juste il me
dit non regardez et en fait en regardant
les deux il y a sur le numéro 8 une
légère inflexion du menton qui se lève
un tout petit peu une est un très joli
un très beau portrait d'un homme assez
beau et l'autre un chef d'État l'autre
est un chef d'État j'adore cette
histoire alors on vous connaît pour
votre travail sur le corps des femmes on
VAC quand même en parler vous vous les
montrez souvent dans une image
hypersxualisée ultra féminine euh et
forte aussi rarement dominée que ce soit
d'ailleurs les striptiseuses des des
débuts de vos premiers shooting ou les
actrices beaucoup d'actrices sous votre
sous votre œil qu'elle soit fatale ou
fragile dans les fameuses chambres
d'hôtel l'obsession de Bettin reins euh
c'est quoi c'est pas des portraits c'est
quoi c'est un jeu euh que vous jouez
entre vous et le modèle d'abord un jeu
d'abord c'est un jeu parce que parce que
les modèles sont enchantés enfin d'aller
poser pour une femme euh il faut vous
dire que quand moi j'ai commencé on
était cinq sur la planète à gagné notre
vie en tant que photographe aujourd'hui
les choses ont beaucoup changé et tant
mieux c'est formidable mais on était des
pionnières euh donc les les femmes
arrivaient
euh stupéfaite de voir que c'était une
femme derrière l'objectif et et et elle
me donnait sans sans risque sans peur ce
qu'elle pouvait refuser à des hommes
parce que le jeu devenait dangereux avec
moi il y a jamais eu de danger et donc
il y a eu une espèce d'énorme complicité
pendant 40 ans avec toutes ces femmes
des femmes célèbres des femmes anonymes
jusqu'à jusqu'au détenu que j'ai
photographié qui était ma dernière série
grande série euh où j'ai passé un en
prison à photographieré des femmes qui
étaient condamnées pour des longues
peines et qui à moi m'ont tout révélé
révélé des choses qu'ell n'avaient
jamais dit même à leur compampagne de
cellules euh et vous êtes une pionnière
c'est vrai femme photographe c'est vrai
vous avez travaillé sur des questions
qui sont absolument partout aujourd'hui
dans le débat public je pense à la
question du genre pour vous c'est une
vieille question parlez-nous de de qui
Marlot euh c'est c'est c'est cette icône
des années quoi qu'on voit à l'antenne
80 c'est le tout début non c'est le
c'est le milieu du la deuxième moitié
des années 80 86 88 qui est une femme TR
et je rencontre pour la première fois
une personne trans et je ne comprends
pas quand elle vient me voir je suis en
train de faire un casting je cherche des
androgyes elle arrive sur des haut
talons avec des cuissardes elle a un
manteau de vison elle semble plus dans
l'imaginaire à Rita àita et W que à que
à une jeune androgine et donc je
comprends au fil de son silence et puis
quand elle se met à parler avec cette
voix un peu grave je comprends que que
c'est pas une femme et et je découvre ce
que c'est que que la transid la
transidentité et d'ailleurs vous rentrez
dans une lien de confiance et il y a une
fameuse photo d'ailleurs exposée à lîle
dans dans cet institut de la
photographie aujourd'hui vous lui
demandé de redevenir le garçon demandé
pendant des années quelle demande quelle
demande demandé pendant des années de me
montrer la photo de son permis de
conduire qu'elle a toujours refusé de me
montrer qui n'a jamais voulu se montrer
à moi comme Alexandre et donc un jour
elle m'a dit je suis prête et on s'est
enfermé et on a fait cette
déconstruction pas vraiment réussie
d'ailleurs parce que si on regarde la
photo d'elle en homme c'estureusement on
l' pas mais j'invite télpectateur mais
c'est une en fait c'est une femme
déguisée en homme elle jamais pu
redevenir ce qu'elle ne voulait plus
être merci beaucoup merci betin arins
donc je renvoie à cette exposition à
l'Institut de la photographie en ce
moment à lî et puis pour les photos
primées et puis un petit livre très joli
qui a fait les qu'on fait les éditions
d'elpire sur Kim et les récits autour de
la vie de Kim VO c'est dit et puis pour
les photos primées pour la photoolitique
ce nouveau prix lancé à l'Assemblée
elles sont dans la salle des pas perdus
au Palais Bourbon donc venez les voir
venez visiter l'Assemblée nationale vous
restez avec moi c'est l'heure des
parties prix nos affranchis qu'on
accueille tout de
suite et on termine cette émission comme
chaque soir avec nos parties prix ce
soir Yanis roder de la Fondation Jean
jores professeur d'histoire ancienne
Saint-Denis et Thomas Lestavel pour
l'économie bienvenue les amis
installez-vous on commence par Bourbon
Express une histoire politique
aujourd'hui polilistique avec Stéphanie
des pierres c'est l'histoire du jour une
histoire de chaise vide oui cell qui
seront autour de la table des rencontres
de Saint-Denis comme en août Emmanuel
Macron invite tous les partis politiques
à venir discuter de l'avenir du pays la
deuxième session est prévue vendredi et
plus ça va et moins il y a du monde
trois chefs de parti qui sont aussi
députés ont déjà décliné l'invitation
alors sans surprise l'insoumis manuel
bonpard mais aussi le socialiste Olivier
fort et à la surprise générale le patron
des républicains Eric cioti alors
pourquoi parce qu'Emmanuel Macron
n'était pas à la marche contre
l'antisémitisme dimanche alors
l'explication est un peu alambiquée dans
sa lettre au président de la République
Eric cioti explique je ne peux
comprendre que vous n'adhériez pas à une
démarche d'unité républicaine pour
combattre l'antisémitisme et que vous
portiez un pseudo message d'unité à
Saint-Denis cela me paraît
contradictoire alors en fait Myriam
cette réunion est surtout une victime
collatérale du débat sur l'immigration
dont vous venez de parler après le vote
par le Sénat et avant l'arrivée de la
loi à l'Assemblée et bien les
républicains veulent afficher leurs
différen avec Emmanuel Macron donc il y
aura pas beaucoup de monde hein à cette
réunion ces rencontres de saint-deny
face au président comment réagit
l'Élysée et bien le président de la
République lui-même vient de réagir
alors qu'il est en visite en Suisse et
c'est assez singlant Emmanuel Macron
juge indigne l'attitude de ses opposants
il estime qu'il commetteent une faute
politique majeure alors avec trois
chaises vides et surtout celle de la
droite la présence du rassemblement
national sera d'autant plus visible il
n'y aura ni le Parti socialiste ni la
France insoumise ni les républicains
est-ce que est-ce que le président
Macron prend pas un peu le risque de se
retrouver presque en tête à-tête avec le
rassemblement national président de la
République est invité tout le monde il
ne va pas aujourd'hui au prétexte que
certains refusent de s'y rendre annuler
ces rencontres ça n'aurait pas de sens
et je vous le rappelle il y a néanmoins
des partis politique de l'opposition qui
ont décidé de venir et c'est pas un tête
à tête avec le rassemblement national
les écologistes ils seront ils l'ont
annoncé pour moi les absents toujours
tort bon on parle des absents les
présents alors évidemment les trois
partis de la alliance présidentielle
mais aussi les centristes de l'UDI et
puis on l'a dit le rassemblement
national et pour la gauche les
écologistes et les communistes mais
finalement quel est l'utilité de ces
rencontres et bien on a demandé aux
députés de l'opposition ce qu'ils en
pensaient à quoi ça sert ces rencontres
de Saint-Denis demander au président de
la République moi je peux pas dire vousz
pas compris aujourd'hui on est un peu
circonspect je n'en sais rien puisque il
n'y a pas grand monde qui va s'y rendre
donc je pense que c'est plutôt un
rendez-vous raté loupé à faire croire
que le Président de la République qui
encore une capacité de rassemblement qui
n'a absolument pas et d'ailleurs la la
la première réunion elle a débouché sur
quoi sur le vide et vu les défections
cette seconde réunion pourrait bien être
bien être la derère la dernière bon on
suivra ça on verra ce qu' peut en sortir
malgré tout Thomas Thomas Lestavel on a
envie de vous entendre parce que ça y
est et bien le chômage repart à la
hausse les chiffres ne sont pas bons ils
ont été publiés ce matin effectivement
ça fait deux trimestres maintenant que
le taux de chômage augmente il est passé
cette année pour l'instant de 7 1 à 7,4
% de la population active et il devrait
s'approcher des 8 % en 2025 alors nous
sortons probablement d'une époque bénie
entre guillemets puisque depuis 2015 le
taux de chômage n'avait fait que baisser
et cette dynamique semble enrayer alors
le gouvernement s'est emprincé de de
relativiser forcément ouais tout à fait
l'exécutif rejette la faute sur la
conjoncture internationale et
honnêtement a raison le ralentissement
économique n'est pas du tout propre à la
France la Commission a revu à la baisse
sa prévision de croissance pour la zone
euro et d'ailleurs si on regarde chez le
voisin allemand le chômage augmente
aussi pourquoi ce ralentissement alors
le principal coupable s'appelle
l'inflation quand les produits coûtent
plus cher encore lui oui quand les
produits coûtent plus cher les ménages
renoncent à acheter ça ralentit
l'activité des entreprises qui donc
recrutent moins et l'autre point c'est
qu'en fait les banques centrales pour
réagir justement à cette inflation et la
freiné ou tenter de la freiner ont
augmenté les taux d'intérêt à des
niveaux inédits depuis plus de 10 ans
donc les entreprises et notamment les
PME ont beaucoup plus de mal à financer
leurs investissements ou leurs projets
et en France s'y ajoute la fin des prê
garantis par par l'État donc les fameux
PGE h
hmfreise avec mosembuche à la clé donc
c'est un coup dur pour Emmanuel Macron
qui avait promis le plein emploi d'ici
2022 ouis effectivement c'était vraiment
un des bilans pour lequel le président
pouvait se flatter d'un succès c'était
sur le front du chômage depuis le
premier quinquena il a mis en place
toute une série de mesures pour stimuler
l'emploi qui au moins dans les chiffres
ont fonctionné donc le plafonnement des
indemnités de licenciement pour que les
entreprise est moins peur d'embaucher il
a rendu les allocations chômage
dégressive développer l'apprentissage et
puis favoriser les reconversions grâce à
la formation et au ce fameux CPF mon
compte formation le gouvernement entend
d'ailleurs poursuivre cette dynamique il
va réformer pas l' emploi on sait que ça
va devenir France travail mais il est
aussi en fait paradoxalement victime de
ses propres réformes et là je pense au
retraite puisque le passage de 62 à 64
ans va mécaniquement augmenter le taux
de chômage on estime environ 0,3 % parce
qui est évidemment beaucoup plus
difficile de trouver un job quand on est
un tout petit mot pour conclure le
paradoxe c'est aussi que on peinene à
recruter on en a pas dans notre débat
c'est ça on en parlait tout à l'heure
donc les les exemples ne manquent pas on
manque de cuisiniers d'ouvriers de
charpentiers d'ambulanciers d'ê soignant
de développeur informatique et j'en
passe et en fait il y a deux solutions à
ça soit on forme les Français au nouveau
métier soit on fait appel à
l'immigration la première mesure ça
coûte cher et ça prend du temps et la
seconde n'a pas la côte en ce moment vu
les SCOR de l'extrême droite donc le
plein emploi c'est pas pour demain bon
merci beaucoup Thomas Yanis vous vouliez
revenir sur le coup de gueule du
ministre de l'Éducation Gabriel Atta
dans Le Parisien c'était hier qui juge
inquiétant le niveau des élèves de 4e et
pour cause Myriam le niveau des élèves
de français de 4e stagne voire régresse
en mathématiqu et en français et le
collège ne parvient pas à réduire les
écarts qui existent entre les élèves à
l'entrée en 6e donc c'est le collège le
problème principal il semblerait Myriam
que le collège ne fasse pas progresser
les nos chers têes blonde un peu plus de
la moitié d'entre eux d'entre elles ne
parvient pas à lire convenablement un
texte et la même proportion ne maîtrise
pas le problème et la géométrie c'est
c'est quand même conséquent pour ce qui
est de la maîtrise de la langue j'avais
souligné en 2008 dans un livre largement
ignoré sauf par ma mère et ma sœur que
mes élèves souffraient d'un manque
criant de vocabulaire comprenant avec
difficulté non seulement les textes mais
également les profs à partir de là les
concepts et l'abstraction leur sont
difficiles voire pour certains
impossible d'accès Jean-Michel Blanquer
avait bien saisi l'enjeu en dédoublant
les petites classes en Rep et en r vous
savez en réseau d'éducation prioritaire
euh et en lançant un grand plan de
formation des enseignants en français et
en mathématique et ça ça marche ça
fonctionne bien bah slab semble
fonctionner puisque Gabriel Atal indique
que les évaluations de 6e sont
meilleures maintenant qu'arrivent les
premières Cortes d'élèves ayant profité
de de ce dispositif mais si arrivriz au
collège il ne progresse plus il va
falloir trouver d'autres solutions
certaines sont avancées par le ministre
création de groupes de niveau en
français et en mathématiqu avec des
effectifs réduits pour les élèves en
difficulté mais aussi augmentation des
horaires dans ces matière pour certains
h et avec quelle chance de de résultat
alors pour certains sans doute ça
fonctionnera mais pour d'autres à mon
sens il ne suffira pas de faire de les
faire davantage travailler pour
progresser parce qu'il y a d'autres
obstacles euh une ambiance agitée en
classe peut gêner certains l'incapacité
des élèves à rester concentré vous savez
les informat spécialistes de Google
ingénieurs de Google ont montré qu'un
enfant fortement soumis aux écrans à une
capacité de concentration de 9 secondes
d'autre part les élèves ont besoin
d'enseignants bien formés et pédagogue
or on manque de prof de français et on
manque de prof de math enfin les élèves
les plus en difficulté souffent parfois
de troubles de l'apprentissage et
d'apprentissag qui n'ont pas été
détectés troubles qui n'ont pas été
détectés en amont et par manque de
psychologue et d'orthophonist qui
pourraiit apporter leur aide donc c'est
d'autant plus vrai dans les espaces de
relélégation sociales où les familles
n'ont pas toujours accès ni aux
structures ni aux spécialistes or la
maîtrise des savoirs fondamentaux et en
premier lieu de la langue est
fondamentale non seulement pour
comprendre le monde dans lequel vie mais
également pour l'insertion sociale et
l'insertion citoyenne de chacun comme
dit Fabrix Lucini la langue française
c'est ce qui nous fonde et nous soude
l'enjeu est aussi là merci merci
beaucoup je crois que vous serez
forcément d'accord cette langue
française absolument absolument je suis
ça avec beaucoup d'intérêt et beaucoup
de d'inquiétude euh j'ai un petit fils
de 9 ans et je trouve qu'il lit pas il
il ne lit pas il est sur son toute la
journé je peux vous dire dans ce cas-là
et ça me désole merci beaucoup merci
bettinaarin d'être venue sur le plateau
d' LCP merci les affranchis on va revoir
peut-être pour terminer la photo du
gagnant de ce prix de la photo politique
Ludovic marin quand les drapiers du
syndicat d'Amsterdam regarde le
président et que les regards s'inversent
entre le tableau et celui bah du chef de
l'État tout simplement bravo à lui venez
à l'assembler voir toutes ces
photographies aller à Lille regardez
celle de Bettina rein très belle soirée
sur LCP et à
[Musique]
demain